hey what's up Samuel lives here and in
this video I'm gonna be giving you my
advice if you're looking to set up a
property business do you want to set up
a buy-to-let investing business these
are things that you need to consider
[Music]
so what are things that you need to do
to sell for buying to let property
business well firstly who the heck am i
I'm Samuel Leeds on the best-selling
author of both these books by low rent
high also financially free in seven days
so if you haven't read those check them
out what are the things you do first
thing is you need to have a goal you
have a business plan any business needs
a business plan so many people say I
want to be a property entrepreneur want
to invest in property they've got no
business plan they don't know where the
one invest they don't know what they
want to achieve from investing they have
no idea so get a pen and paper even if
you just start by writing down but what
the why you know why do you want to do
property what are you hoping to achieve
from property investing here's what's a
first thing is have an outcome so the
outcome might be more far away so in 12
months time the outcome is that I am
making three thousand pounds a month
which enables me to quit my job that's
the outcome then when you've got the
outcome I would advise then writing down
the activity so the activity that you
need to do to make that outcome a
reality and also don't put the activity
down for the for the year don't say the
activity is only to do you know over the
next 12 months names doing this listen
listen this no write down the activity
over the next two weeks so the outcome
for the year and the activity that I
need to start to make this happen and
for build the momentum in the next two
weeks because otherwise you know like
it's like last-minute calm if you've got
something to do or if it's Christmas and
you need to get the shop and you always
go out on like the 21st of December and
do it in the same if you've got 12 month
goal you'll relax and who cares I'll get
to it later you'll be procrastinating
and putting things off two weeks not
even a goal the activity that you need
to take maybe that'll be I need to go to
these networking events and interview
this many houses and it's putting this
many offers I need to introduce myself
to the local estate agent this is the
kind of activity the internet in the
next few weeks really important things
number one have a business plan have a
goal and have your planned activity next
number two Power Team stop putting your
power team together and
great thing is when you have your
business plan and you have your goal you
can tell your members of the power team
what your business plan is and see how
they fit with that so go to your local
estate agent and say hey my plan is I
want to buy three houses in the next 12
months and I want to view ten houses in
the next two weeks that are this kind of
house can you help me speak to an
accountant
say hey this is my plan this is my
business plan my short business plan
don't spend three minutes writing your
business plan you can bang out right now
today but this is my business plan can
you help me speak to a solicitor speak
to a management company start speaking
to people speak to a mentor you know and
say this is my business plan and start
building your power team who are the
people that are gonna support and make
it happen in your business plan number
three view lots of properties I would
say the person who views the most houses
wins so just stop viewing houses and you
might think I'm not ready to view houses
I'm not ready I need to um I need to get
my business plan more accurate I need to
spend a few years on that first or I
need to you know get my mortgage in
principle I don't know just just just
start viewing houses when you start
viewing houses things just start to
happen next thing is you then stop point
offers in if you view a house and then
put an offer in and then the estate
agent says offer accept it we need your
mortgage in principle you'll get your
mortgage in principle in the next ten
minutes because y'all no choices
oh my gosh you need to get it done fast
urgent where did you go
I'll get my movies in principle and then
overview houses it can take forever so
just take lots of massive action and
start viewing houses because ultimately
you want to build a by to let business
that's going to come from houses even if
you don't put any offers in just go to
auctions go and sit with estate agents
asking what's around start viewing
houses do it as a hobby a lot of my
success students to have become very
wealthy in property they said that
instead of playing on the Xbox or
watching box sets and just started view
houses instead don't take your missus do
it have it as a date just view houses
number four I'm really reluctant to say
this one it is important but I know that
this is the one that you'll want to do
the most and this is the one that you're
but all the others are to do this one so
do this important but don't stop doing
the others but this one is you should at
some point have business cards or
website and flyers where do you get
these from you can set up a website
really quickly really cheaply on wix.com
you don't need a fancy side you can see
the site so that when you go to an
estate agent and you put forward an
offer or are you speaking to people in
the networking and they say well who are
you you can say look I'm actually Samuel
Eve's here's my card
it looks professional on the card
there's a website they own slippers like
it just makes you look more professional
if you want to do business with people
that people would just take you more
seriously now you don't need a business
card or a website or flyers in order to
make money but it just helps when you're
when you have a business people expect
you you if you see yourself as a
professional property business person
you need a website you need a business
cards very simple don't spend more than
75 pound on the website and don't spend
more than maybe 100 pounds getting your
first batch of cards you know they've
2,000 business cards you just need a few
hundred you know hand them out sparingly
don't just dish them out don't go to
networking events and go hey you have a
car don't spam everybody know instead of
collect other people's cards and then
put them on your list and grow your list
and just have them ready when you when
you need to introduce yourself properly
but don't spam people the Flyers when I
say flights like a leaflet you shouldn't
be giving that out to everybody the
flyer is if you see a property maybe
it's got two boards outside it now it's
with Dixons and also with Jamin and you
think oh I've got two boards outside the
property looks like it is a bit of a
reefer I've got a feeling that it then
motivated first my house you just pop a
flyer or a leaflet through the door you
know when you're driving around you see
something interesting you see an
interesting property get it out put it
through the door keep the leaflets in
your dashboard so just helps you as a
business person makes you more
professional and it will ultimately help
people give you more leads and deals
lastly number five get the training get
the training like people say something
you only go on about the training
because you've run training no no don't
get it twisted it's the other way around
I only run training because I know how
important it is that training exists so
if you want to be a doctor you've got to
get the training and you better get
qualified people to be a hairdresser
upon any any professional you've got to
get the training same with property
investment the sad thing is a lot of
property investors they have no training
because they're you know half half
trying to get a qualification to invest
in property to have a have a void to let
business you don't have to but if you
don't you'll lose tens maybe hundreds of
thousands of pounds and you'll leave
money on the table and you'll
potentially get burned and look stupid
so just turn the class company we want a
training company you know come down get
the experience from other people don't
make the mistakes yourself get the
experience from other people I think the
most important thing in to invest in
before you invest in property is to
invest in yourself because once you've
got that kind of the right kind of
knowledge and you know how to stack a
deal and you know how to find yo so just
get training I invest in myself today
I've spent two hundred and sixty four
thousand pounds in the last 12 months on
my training so I really believe in
training because the bigger you grow the
bigger your capacity is to make more
money and hold more money so get the
training so to summarize have a business
plan set up a Power Team view lots of
houses and make lots of offers get a
website and business cards and get the
training and invest in yourself if you
do these five things your buy-to-let
property business will blow up in the
next 12 months and I can't wait to see
you succeeding if you've had any
successes from property as a result of
my training or these YouTube videos
please do let me know because who knows
we could bring you on winners on a
Wednesday every week we have success
stories also don't forget to read the
box while I read my these books
financially free in seven days you know
it's good stuff it's good stuff it will
serve you well so comment below I'll see
you next time thank you so much for
watching I really appreciate your time
you
[Music]